good afternoon has anyone taken
professor maschwitz is immunology course
some people how about you people
listening any of you nobody I guess then
well today we're gonna talk about host
defense one lecture for host defense so
obviously this for many of you will be a
repeat although maybe not with the viral
emphasis that I'm going to give it to
you today and for the others there's a
lot of information in the textbook that
can fill in the gaps so these are we
view the host defense against infections
in sort of three stages if you will the
first being the physical and chemical
defenses that are nonspecific your skin
surface coatings of mucous membranes low
pH etc then what we call the frontline
defense the intrinsic defense systems
which you'll hear more about from
Professor silverstein the detection by
the innate immune system production of
cytokines and so forth and then finally
the attack and cleanup the adaptive
immune defense is led by antibodies and
and t-cells of various sorts another way
to look at it is shown here you have a
pathogen impinging on us not shown here
are the intrinsic defenses the the
nonspecific ones if the pathogen gets by
that is recognized by pattern
recognition receptors if there is no
recognition as a pathogen that's the end
but if it is recognized as being foreign
and we'll talk a bit about how that
happens this activates a number of arms
the cytokines are produced dendritic
cells are recruited in part by the
cytokines and this comprises the innate
response to infection if the pathogen
would happen to bypass the innate
response then the adaptive response is
engaged and this results in the end in
the production of very specific B and T
cells which hopefully will eliminate the
pathogen and eventually the
establishment of memory
of that pathogen so that if it's
encountered again you have a very rapid
response I view the immune system in
this way three walls of higher height
the first is the intrinsic defenses if a
virus gets over that its encounters the
innate immunity wall and if it gets over
that then we have acquired immunity and
then if it gets over that then
unfortunately the host is in big trouble
so let's start with the innate immune
responses we're gonna bypass a lot of
the intrinsic responses as I said dr.
Silverstein will talk about those innate
immune responses are always active in
the host without any exposure to virus
and they are typically activated very
quickly after infection and it's the
only immune defense available for the
first few days after an infection so
until your adaptive defense is kicking
you're at the mercy of your innate
system and so it's very very important
the innate response comprises cytokines
which we'll talk about Sentinel cells
including dendritic cells and
macrophages complement and NK or natural
killer cells and the activation of the
innate response relies on the
recognition of a foreign pathogen by
various patterns and these are molecular
motifs that are found only in microbes
and as I said earlier the innate
response is able to communicate with the
adaptive response that it will inform it
when replication has exceeded a certain
a certain threshold and the innate
response can't handle it any longer
an important component of the innate
response is recognizing that a microbe
is foreign and not self and this is
something that has only developed in the
past thirty years or so it's biggest
story begins in 1980 when two German
scientists they're working on Drosophila
not viruses they were trying to identify
genes and involved in pattern
development in flies and the story goes
that Christian knew saline ball hard
looked at a fly one day
it was really weirdly malformed so she's
a - wash at all which means wow that's
that's pretty cool or far out and so she
ended up calling them the tole genes
that controlled this particular
phenotype and this was very important
finding and she got the Nobel Prize for
that in 1995 we call them the toll
receptors now in 1996 this gene the toll
gene was then found to have a role in
immunity of the flight to fungal
infection so for all this period from
nineteen eighty to ninety six we knew it
had a role in development of the fly but
only in ninety six shown to have a role
in innate immunity so flies just having
an eight immune system so this is an
important component of it and in 1997
toll-like receptors were identified in
mammals and that's what we're going to
talk about today toll-like receptors
these are type 1 transmembrane proteins
pattern Ricky they are pattern
recognition receptors they recognize a
pathogen associated molecular pattern
also called a PAMP and they are
conserved from plants insects all the
way to humans highly conserved proteins
14 members that we know about the
extracellular domains consist of what we
call leucine-rich repeat they're just
repeats of a leucine-rich domain and the
cytoplasmic domains are related to
similar domains in the interleukin 1
receptor family so they're called
tall / il-1 receptor domains these
cytoplasmic domains or tier domains so
these are the toll-like receptors known
so far and the patterns that they
recognize so these are patterns that are
specific for microbes not us so these
tlrs recognize these individual patterns
as foreign and the ones we will consider
mainly for viruses are tlr-2 viral
glycoproteins double-stranded RNA tlr3
viral glycoproteins also tlr4 and then
TLR seven and eight recognize
single-stranded RNA the other tlrs
recognize components of bacteria and
fungi
so again these are components that are
not within us but are recognized as
foreign so here are some diagrams of the
tlrs here's the original protein encoded
by the toll gene of distress Avila
called spatzle and you can see it is a
transmembrane protein it has a
cytoplasmic tear domain right here and
then the extracellular domain composed
of many of these leucine-rich repeat and
here are all the TLRs in other species
from tlr-1
to attend and there's some of the
components that they recognized here so
again composed of different arrangements
of leucine rich repeats the crystal
structure of the extracellular domain of
toll-like receptor 3 has been solved you
can see it here each of these lines
essentially is a leucine-rich repeat and
you can see it forms a curved molecule
so this recognizes these foreign
antigens and RNAs
now the toll-like receptors can be
located in in different places on cells
some of them are in the plasma membranes
and recognized viral components in the
extracellular fluids but many of them
are on the the inner endosome membrane
so here is a cell here's the cytoplasm
in the nucleus and this would be an
endosome and you can see the tail are 3
7 8 & 9
all of these recognizing RNA are in the
interior of the endosome so that when
viruses are endocytosed and they deposit
their nucleic acid into the endosome or
when dyeing cell pieces are taken up by
the cell the nucleic acid ends up in the
endosome it can be sensed by the
toll-like receptors and those set that
sensing then initiates a sing a signal
transduction pathway involving
phosphorylation of various transcription
proteins IRF 3 NF kappa-b
their entry into the nucleus and then
the production of cytokines including
interferon so some of these cytokines
are produced so that's the end result of
when a TLR senses something being
foreign in
initiates a signaling cascade and you
have the production of cytokines which
are a key component of the innate
response now how this works is not
entirely understood yet have say a
ligand activates a toll-like receptor
the current model for RNA at least which
is shown here is that the extracellular
domain of T L R this is tlr3 binds RNA
and that's the RNA is shown here is a
great coil and then the binding of RNA
leads to dimerization of the T L R and
that is important for signaling so the
dimerization of monomers of tlr3 here
initiate the signaling which will then
produce the cytokines in the cell there
is an addition to these TLRs which are
membrane bound sensors there are two
cytoplasmic proteins that also sense
viral RNAs one of them is shown here
it's called rig I and it is as I said in
the cytoplasm and it senses the presence
of viral RNAs in the cytoplasm not every
virus puts its RNA or DNA into the
endosome and to cover that we have these
cytoplasmic helicase these are called
rig I like HeLa cases one is regarding
the other is MDA v so these would
recognize viral RNA as specifically
being foreign and that also initiates a
signaling cascade which leads to the
production of inflammatory cytokines so
we have two systems a membrane bound
system in a cytoplasmic system for
sensing molecules as foreign this is a
model for how these cytoplasmic sensors
would detect RNA as foreign these at
both rig-i and MDA v they both are very
similar in structure and here's a model
on the left for what they look like they
have an N terminal card domain they have
a helicase domain in the central portion
at the end of c-terminal domain and they
are present in the cell in an inactive
form they cannot signal they cannot turn
on cytokine synthesis in this form when
they recognize viral RNA the viral RNA
binds the c-terminal domain
folds the protein activates it so that
it can now participate in signaling and
the card domain is essential for that
the card domain interacts with
downstream proteins and that is exposed
when these proteins bind RNA the way
that the RNA is recognized as foreign is
that these proteins recognize either
double-stranded RNA which is typically
not present in an uninfected cell so
many viruses make double-stranded RNA
during transcription or replication so
if that sensed these proteins assume
it's foreign in the nation they initiate
the induction of cytokines or RNA
single-stranded RNA with five prime
phosphate this is again not something
that is found in cells cellular messages
have caps and other RNAs ribosomal RNAs
are typically confined to the nucleus so
the only mess the only RNA with five
prime phosphate in the cytoplasm is
going to be a viral RNA so again that's
why these sensors classify it as foreign
so here's another view of this pathway
to give you a little more detail here is
rig AI and MDA v recognizing various
kinds of RNAs they could be negative or
positive stranded it doesn't matter as
long as they have phosphates or they can
be double stranded when these sensors
are activated by binding to RNA that
card domain then interacts with a
mitochondrial protein called Mavs and
then that initiates the signaling
through a variety of pathways leading to
activation of transcription proteins IR
F 3 rf7 NF kappa-b these go in the
nucleus and here we're showing the
production of interferon by assembly of
a variety of these proteins on the
promoter so the point here is that they
sense the RNA in the cytoplasm and then
the end result is the production of
cytokines and one of those cytokines is
interferon or interference which is a
family of proteins these were first
discovered in 1957 by Isaacs and
Lindemann who found that if you expose
chicken cells to inactivated influenza
virus those cells would produce
something in the medium which if you
added to another cell would protect them
from influenza virus infection so they
said it interfered with infection so
they called it interferon there are a
couple of different types as we'll show
you in a moment
interferon alpha beta or the type 1
interferons these appear first after
infection followed by interferon gamma
virus infected cells typically induce
the synthesis of interferon alpha beta
there are in as part of the innate
system what we call Sentinel cells
macrophages and dendritic cells these
produce alpha beta interferon in
response to products released from
infected cells so as we'll see dendritic
cells will scavenge the pieces of dead
cells that result from a viral infection
like nucleic acid they will sense that
nucleic acid and then they will produce
interferon alpha beta so you don't have
to infect a cell to produce interferons
the Sentinel cells can make it after
sensing the products of a dead cell so
here are four different types of
interferon that we are aware of
interferon alpha and beta these are the
type 1 interferons alpha is made in most
cells and it's induced by virus
infection interferon beta as well most
cells induced by virus infection
interferon gamma is mainly made by T
cells and natural killer cells and it is
a it is induced by T cell receptor
activation which happens when itting
when a T cell engages a ligand and these
2 cytokines in particular we've learned
most recently of a type 3 interferon
called interferon lambda mainly produced
by epithelial cells so the respiratory
tract an elementary tracked epithelium
remember is a good place for viruses to
enter and apparently those cells have
their own special kind of interferon
that protects them so we're not going to
talk very much about this but this is a
brand new and very intense area of
research the production of type 1
interferons that is alpha beta is very
quick after infection within hours so
you have a burst of interferon
production and then it declines by 10
hours
and alpha so there's one gene for
interferon beta but for alpha there are
many and these seem to be differentially
expressed in other words different sets
of alpha genes are expressed depending
on the virus so the interferon beta as I
said is stimulated only for a short
period of time so by ten hours the
synthesis of protein declines now these
proteins work on cells that have
receptors for them so interferon alpha
will only affect a cell that has a
receptor for interferon alpha in fact
alpha and beta share the same receptor
the type 1 interferon receptor what
these proteins do is to induce the
synthesis of still more proteins and
they by doing so they make what we call
an antiviral state so we say the
interferon is produced in response to
the virus infection and the interferon
makes an antiviral state and that
happens when interferon binds to
receptors on cells and that induces the
production over a thousand cell proteins
which are encoded by genes called
interferon stimulated genes or is G's so
the is G's of the genes whose
transcription is stimulated by
interferon they in turn or make mRNAs
that are translated to make all these
proteins so all of these proteins that
are involved in establishing an
antiviral state most of these we have no
idea how they work these is G's it's
only in the last few years or so that
we've known that there's over a thousand
it started years ago with a few and then
10 20 50 100 and then with microarray
technology it went over a thousand so
most of them are unknown and this is a
really active area of research and
probably it's true that mixtures of
different is G's are made in response to
different viruses and or or I should say
are effective for inhibiting different
virus infections so what happens is when
interferon is produced by ACE an
infected cell say or even by an
uninfected dendritic cell it
fuses out of the cell it's secreted from
the cell and then binds to interferon
receptors these can be on the same cell
or on another cell doesn't really matter
so here we have interferon the type 1
interferon receptor for interferon alpha
beta is in the middle and here's
interferon gamma receptor The Binding of
interferon to these receptors leads to
association with protein kinases the
jack and tic protein kinases those
phosphorylate the stat proteins which
then dimerize and go into the nucleus
and activate the transcription of the is
jeez alright so another signaling
cascade from the binding of interferon
to its receptor to the production of
transcripts encoding all of the thousand
or more is G's so that happens with both
interferon alpha beta and gamma as shown
here so let's talk about a few of these
interferon induced proteins one of them
is PKR which we've encountered already
we talked about this during translation
this is the double stranded RNA
activated protein kinase so it's induced
by interferon its mrna is induced by
interferon and then the the PKR itself
of course has to be activated by double
stranded RNA so it then is activated at
phosphorylate CIF to alpha inhibits
translation so this is a major is G
because remember every virus has evolved
a way to get around the activity of PKR
can inhibit very many viruses and also
the phosphorylated form triggers a
programmed cell death which is another
intrinsic response to infection to kill
the cell and try and limit virus
replication another interferon induced
protein is RNA cell there two of them
here RNA cell and 2 prime 5 prime I'll
ago a synthetase so these are 2 separate
proteins encoded by 2 genes which work
together what happens here is again a
virus infects the cell interferons made
and this is one of the mo these are two
of the mRNAs that are turned on they're
made into proteins 2 prime 5 prime OAS
is inactive as it's produced it's
activated by viral RNA double stranded
by
RNA once it's activated it uses ATP as a
substrate and synthesizes 2 prime 5
prime I'll ago a so polymerizes a and
it's very specific way that product is
then required to activate RNA cell so
this is an enzyme that degrades viral
RNA it's inactive as produced is induced
by interferon but in the presence of 2
prime 5 prime alig away it can become
activated and then it degrades mrna okay
so it's a two component system which I
suppose ensures that it's only turned on
in a virus infected cell and the end
result is degradation of mRNA MX
proteins are also interferon induced
these were first discovered in mice and
was shown to localize in the nucleus and
block the cap snatching by the virus
remember cap snatching is needed to
prime synthesis of viral mRNA s so this
protein blocks that by inhibiting the PB
2 protein of the virus however mice
don't have influenza viruses and in
nature we can infect them in the lab
which is how this work was done but in
nature there are no flu viruses of mice
and a good amount of the mouse
population lacks the gene encoding this
protein so at least in mice it doesn't
have much to do with into influenza
antiviral activity but there are human
homologs MX a and M X B and the MX a
protein blocks the replication of a
couple of different viruses as you see
here so a nice example of how studying
antiviral effects in mice led to
identification of human genes with the
same activity nitric oxide synthase is
another interferon induced gene product
it's interfere it's induced by
interferon gamma not alpha beta and a
nitric oxide synthase shown here in the
blue box takes arginine and makes nitric
oxide from it and nitric oxide has
antiviral effects either on its own
or it can be further converted to peroxy
nitrite which is a highly reactive
compound either one nitric oxide or
peroxy nitrite both react with proteins
and destroy their activity so here you
can see nitric oxide is reacting with
this cloud-like protein here and it's
rendering it inactive so it's nitrated
basically and this protein is inactive
so in an infection what happens is this
enzyme is induced nitric oxide is
produced and it's typically produced
locally right near the infected area so
here we have a epithelial cell monolayer
infected by a virus here little virus
particles around here the infection has
stimulated the influx of macrophages or
NK cells into this area coming from the
circular circulation to the infected
cell these now produce nitric oxide and
they kill these cells basically so
they're destroying their own cells but
in in the process they're preventing
virus production so the loss of some
cells is considered evolutionarily at
least not a bad exchange for stopping
the virus infection okay so this results
in local eradication of infected cells
these do cause pathology as you would
expect in fact in mice you can you can
make mice that don't have the gene for
nitric oxide synthase and for some virus
infections there's less damage tissue
damage in those animals than if they had
the gene so it's responsible for some of
the pathology of virus infection but
it's evolutionarily conserved because it
must have a selective advantage
promyelocytic leukemia
more about these from dr. Silverstein
these are present and in the nucleoplasm
and nuclear bodies they're called
they're called by a variety of names PML
bodies and D tens pods what they do is
they bind foreign DNA and they exert an
antiviral effect by inhibit
transcription and the remodeling of
nucleosomes and many virus infections
disrupt the formation of PML bodies
because they would have an antiviral
effect by inhibiting DNA replication so
they are a common target of antiviral
Intag viral antagonists a number of
components of the ubiquitin proteasome
axis are is G's for example is g15 is a
protein much like ubiquitin that is
conjugated to cell proteins that are
involved in a variety of activities that
viruses need and this leads to their
degradation so it's a and they're also
ubiquitin ligases that are a part of
that are also is GS and these are of
course enzymes that attach ubiquitin to
proteins this targets them for
degradation so the idea being you target
viral proteins for degradation and that
include that helps with the antiviral
response and you can show that these
have some consequence because you can
add inhibitors of the proteosome so when
you a ubiquitinated protein it targets
it to the proteosome which is a massive
Center in the cell for degrading
proteins and if you add inhibitors of
the proteosome you can show that you
block the antiviral action of interferon
in this case hepatitis B virus so these
have antiviral effects and that's why we
think they are is G's now here's a very
new is G recently understood it's called
tetherin or CD 137 this is a very
interesting is G it is actually a
transmembrane protein here's the
configuration on the upper left here's
the cell membrane and this tether and
the n-terminus is in the cytoplasm then
it crosses the membrane and has an
extracellular domain and then it's
anchored it's C terminus is anchored in
the plasma membrane as well this protein
has the property of being able to
prevent the budding of many envelope
viruses from cells then it shut the
light off a moment
you can see this here's an electron
micrograph of cells expressing tether
and the tetherin has been stained so
that it appears here as black dots so
this is all tethering and you can see
these virions are stuck at the surface
and here's on the right as a schematic
of how this works the tether ins are the
green molecules so they're they're
hooking the viruses to the surface and
to each other so they can't move off of
the cell and they can't spread so this
has a distinct antiviral activity and
inhibits retroviruses a couple of other
envelope viruses now as you might guess
the viruses have evolved ways to
antagonize tetherin as well okay some
other is G's is g56 this is a protein
that binds a subunit of Vi f3 remember
if 3 is a protein involved in
translation it binds gif 4g and the
bridges if 4g and the 40s subunit so
helps bring in the 40s subunit to mRNA
so that the effect of this binding - we
have three is that it blocks protein
synthesis this is not virus specific but
again many of these is G's are not
specific for virus functions they shut
down cellular functions and that
includes the virus because as you know
viruses or parasites of cells and that
stops the infection micro RNAs are
actually introduced by induced by
interferon treatment of hepatoma cells
with interferon beta induces the
production of numerous micro rnas eight
of which inhibit the replication of
hepatitis C virus so it's not a protein
but it's an interferon stimulated gene
micro RNAs interestingly interferon beta
treatment of cells reduces the
expression of Mir 122 and I believe we
talked about this few lectures ago Mir
122 is a cellular micro RNA that is
actually required for the replication of
hepatitis C virus and it's a liver
specific micro RNA so interferon reduces
the expression of this and
ISG in the sense but it is still an
effective interferon that has an
antiviral effect very interesting okay
let's move on now to the sentinel cells
another part of the innate response
these are dendritic cells and
macrophages these exist in peripheral
compartments your skin mucosal surfaces
first described as Langerhans cells in
the late nineteenth century and then in
1973 Ralph Steinman and Zam Bell cone
here in New York City called them
dendritic cells and these exist as
immature cells initially they're found
in the periphery body cavities under
mucosal surfaces so remember the nice
mucosa that are beautiful sites of virus
entry these sentinels are below them
they're always patrolling making sure
that nothing is bad is happening they
have a whole variety of receptors
toll-like receptors they have the rig I
like HeLa cases and their cytoplasm they
have cytokine receptors and we'll see
what those are for in a moment so
they're present in the periphery and
body cavities as immature DCs
when they when they sense something that
shouldn't be there they get activated
they mature and they go to your lymph
node and there they talk to lymphocytes
they say look what I found look at this
antigen what do you think about this and
then the T cells the other lymphocytes
take over from there so it's a way of
linking the innate and adaptive
responses if the innate can't can't
handle the infection you've got the
adaptive response ready to kick in so
the dendritic cells are important links
between the two they can also make a lot
of interferon so they can sense they can
be underneath that mucosal layer they
can sense virus infected cells by the
products of dying cells they can they
can sense viral RNA for example and they
can produce a lot of interferon to try
and protect that mucosa before they run
off into the lymph node to inform the
lymphocytes soldiers so on the left here
is a diagram of a immature dendritic
cell nothing particularly unusual about
it except it has a lot of interesting
receptors it has toll-like receptors on
the surfaces and also in the end of
psalms
it has receptors for various cytokines
that will help mature it and in its
endosome it has MHC class 2 receptors so
when this dendritic cell encounters say
the products of a killed sell at a
mucosal layer it will endocytosis it's
very good at taking up endocytosis a
material it will detect it as foreign by
these tlrs and RL RS and then it becomes
matured and it becomes a very
nice-looking spidery type of cell shown
on the right it's got a lot more surface
area so it can display a lot more
receptors for maturation all these class
2 molecules are now on the cell surface
and they are presenting these peptides
that they found at the mucosal layer two
T cells in the lymph node so they move
to the lymph node from the periphery
they present the antigen to the T cell
and they also produce cytokines that
will help the T cell mature if the T
cell recognizes this as a foreign
peptide then boom it starts becoming
activated and then becomes a an
activated t cell for going and getting
rid of the virus infection and we'll
talk about that in a bit
so these guys are sentinels they hang
out in different areas and when there's
something produced that it shouldn't be
they take it up and present it to T
cells in the lymph node now some viruses
just an aside here some viruses can do
things to dendritic cells so you don't
have to infect a dendritic cell to enact
to activate it in fact the dendritic
cell just picks up pieces of viral
destruction in the periphery and gets
activated but some viruses actually
infect them and it's very smart to do
this for example HIV one binds a protein
on the surface of DCs called DC sign all
right it's just a protein that's there
for other reasons but HIV has evolved to
attach to it it doesn't go into the DC
it just stays stuck on it the the
dendritic cell is activated by the
presence of the virus so what does it do
it runs to the lymph node what's in the
lymph node t-cells what is HIV in fact
t-cells so it
a nice strategy to find the cells that
you have to infect so the Sentinels
bring unwittingly HIV to the place where
they want to replicate kind of like a
Trojan horse I suppose another virus an
RNA virus Venezuelan and equine
encephalitis virus and dengue virus will
actually enter dendritic cells and
replicate them and then as the viruses
are replicating they go that the DC's go
to the lymph nodes what they usually do
and then they produce and release virus
and then from there it can spread the
different parts of a body so this is
actually under consideration as a
vaccine strategy if you and activate the
virus so that it doesn't spread the DC
will bring it to the lymph node where
then that you have a very potent
antiviral immune stimulation infection
of these cells can also have other
consequences besides these two that we
have shown here of course if you destroy
the sentinels you're going to dampen the
immune response that can interfere with
maturation you can even interfere with
the maturation of T cells because the
dendritic cells have to produce
cytokines that the T cells need in order
to mature so those viruses that do
infect these sentinels are doing for
them it's a it's a good thing another
component of the innate response is
complement or the complement cascade
identified in 1890 as something in serum
that was sensitive to heat that would
lyse bacteria when antibodies against
the bacteria are present so they said
this complemented the activity of
antibodies so they call it complement
now complement is a major defense system
that bridges innate and adaptive
defenses in a different way as dendritic
cells do and it is a collection of serum
and membrane proteins many many
different components not just a single
protein as you will see in a moment and
it can recognize pathogens as foreign by
pattern recognition and help bring in
antibodies to engage so the antibodies
of course are the product of the
adaptive response complement is an early
and eight system and once antibodies are
made
compliment which is already produced
early on innate responses will combine
with these antibodies to eliminate
invaders so this can work both early and
late in infection or actually some
antibodies that are present already in
all of us against various viral
components so the activation of
complement early on can have benefits
we'd have to wait for the production of
virus specific antibody so there are
four functions of complement for ways
that it works first that it breaks cells
it kills them it pokes holes in them
these are typically infected cells that
have some viral proteins on the surface
that could be bound by antibodies to
those proteins so say let's say an
envelope virus is putting its
glycoproteins in the plasma membrane and
if you've already antibodies against
that those antibodies will bind the
protein and then complement comes along
and sees this antibody sitting on the
cell and it will lyse the cell seidel
Isis can also activate inflammation it
can induce the synthesis of cytokines
we'll talk about what inflammation is in
a moment and why it's good for you
it can help coat virus particles to
facilitate them being taken up and
destroyed by macrophages or phagocytic
cells this is called opsonization and it
can solubilize
immune complexes so when you do have an
adaptive immune response you're making a
lot of antibodies against foreign
epitopes when they those antibodies bind
to foreign proteins they tend to clog
very small capillaries these are called
immune complexes so particularly in your
kidney and brain very tiny capillaries
which are easily clogged by immune
complexes so you can get glomerular
nephritis for example an inflammation of
the kidney as a consequence of
complement plays a role in keeping these
apart not letting them aggregate so
here's one example of how complement
works you can see there are many
proteins involved these are all
components of the complement cascade you
don't have to know any of them all you
need to know is what complement does so
here for example is an example of one of
the
complement components c1q forming a
structure called c1 and this can
actually code virus particles and have
to have them be taken up by macrophages
c1 can also recognize antibodies bound
on the cell surface so this brown line
is the cell surface so here's a viral
antigen being produced it's a
transmembrane protein of some kind
antibodies can recognize it and then
this c1 structure will recognize that
and then it activates this whole cascade
that follows here with all these jiggly
red arrows so these are a variety of
proteins that are made there's a lot of
processing going on here these various
soluble components here C 3 a c 5 c 5 a
these can induce the production of
cytokines by different cell types so
that's why they are called mediators of
inflammation and then finally at the end
of all this you have the formation of a
pore the membrane attack complex this
pokes a hole in this cell and lysis it
so this has all become this is all
stemming from the initial recognition by
c1 of antibody bound to the surface of
the cell that we're not virus infected
the antibody wouldn't be bound here so
that's why it's specific for virus
infected cells so that's what we've
talked about so far the innate defense
system cytokines the pattern recognition
molecules tlrs and RL RS we haven't
talked about NK cells but they're also
an important component and the
complement system and again they take
care of most infections very early on
your innate system is often kicking into
play and it takes care of things without
you knowing it
but sometimes these are breached by
viruses and then in that case the innate
system has signaled the adaptive system
that it needs help and the adaptive
system can kick in now some of the main
products of the innate response are
cytokines and we divided them into three
primary classes we have the
pro-inflammatory cytokines such as I l1
and TNF these promote the activation of
various white blood cells for example
the T cells in them in the vicinity of
the dendritic cell and we have other
cytokines that are anti-inflammatory
their purpose is to balance the activity
of the pro-inflammatory cytokines so
once an infection has been taking care
of these return the system to its normal
basal state and then there are a variety
of chemokines whose job it is to a
recruit immune cells so if there's an
area that's infected chemokines are
produced and they recruit additional
cells to the area to help clear the
infection so cytokines initially are
produced locally at a mucosal surface
where there are virus infections going
on those cells release material that
activate say dendritic cells to produce
cytokines and chemokines the chemokines
then pull in other cells to the area
macrophages and lymphocytes so the
lymphocytes say that are maturing in the
time in the lymph node are pulled here
by chemokines initially cytokines
function locally
that's your mucosal surface but if
infection is proceeding it's not
controlled you get more and more
cytokines produce eventually they get
into your circulation and they have
global effects so here we have IL one
TNF alpha il six entering the
circulation and they give you the
typical nonspecific symptoms of a viral
infection sleepiness lethargy muscle
pain no appetite nausea also symptoms of
a virologist
and that's why you feel this way when
you have a virus infection because
you're making these wonderful cytokines
are circulating and they are doing this
to you the cytokines also go into your
bone marrow and stimulate hematopoiesis
to make more cells to fight infections
phagocytic cells and other sorts of
cells as well so cytokines have an
important role very early starting very
early in infection the cytokines also
induce inflammation what we call
inflammation all right and in particular
TNF alpha tumour necrosis factor-alpha
is a major inducer of inflammation
what is inflammation redness pain heat
and swelling boob or dole or kala or two
more the Romans first
described inflamation way back the
ancient Romans not today's Romans but
the ancient ones long ago recognized
inflamation that they gave it those four
words which lasts today redness pain
heat and swelling these are all the
cause of cytokines produced early in the
innate response you get increased blood
flow increased capillary permeability
influx of faggus if a gas it excels and
tissue damage all of that is responsible
for these four signs of inflammation and
again caused by cytokines produced by
the innate response including TNF alpha
so here's a very nice picture that sort
tries to integrate what I have told you
so far and in particular integrating the
circulatory system the blood stream with
the lymph system of course you know that
in addition to a blood system of a
system of extensive system of blood
vessels and capillaries we also have a
lymph system consisting of lymph vessels
of different sizes from capillaries all
the way up to larger ones interspersed
with lymph nodes and these are spread
throughout the body
because remember the dendritic cells go
to the lymph nodes at some point to
signal them that something is wrong so
in this case we have an infection right
here near the lymph vessel it's it's
it's in red color it's labeled antigen
so imagine there's some cells here that
are infected and they're the viruses
killing cells and proteins and RNAs are
being released dendritic cells which are
patrolling this area all the time they
will pick up those components become
matured they go to lymph nodes and there
they activate the production of
lymphocytes and we have our T cells and
B cells coming back to the area how do
they know where to go because they're
chemokines produced locally by the
dendritic cells so they come back here
and they start to try and eliminate the
infection in addition we activate
complement by the mechanisms we talked
about the complement activates
phagocytic cells and a variety of other
cells that produce cytokines and
chemokines as well and a lot of those
here's
you're il-1 TNF alpha interferon gamma
they they have effects on the blood
vessels so they make the blood vessels
more permeable they cause migration of
macrophages from within the circulation
to the infected area so that's how we
have this orchestration between the
lymph and the blood system in an
infected area and again the consequences
of all these cytokine releases early on
is inflammation the swelling redness
heat and pain inflammation is good for
you
it stimulates potent immune defenses
cytopathic viruses that is viruses that
kill cells they cause inflammation
because they damage the cell so if a
virus kills a cell you have bits of dead
cell floating around in virus parts and
those are picked up by the dendritic
cells and that's good so the dendritic
cell can sense that there's an infection
if the cell isn't being killed it's very
hard to sense that it's infected so
that's why inflammation is good it means
that the dendritic cells have sensed
something foreign they're producing
cytokines and so forth and inflammation
so inflammation sorry cell that cell and
tissue damage activates the innate
response leading to inflammation so
viral genomes from cytopathic viruses
typically encode proteins that modulate
the induction of inflammation as you
will see from dr. Silverstein they have
to otherwise they would be eliminated by
the inflammatory response and in viruses
herpes viruses pox virus is the viruses
with larger DNA genomes that have a lot
of room to spare they encode extra
proteins that specifically antagonize
innate responses they don't want to be
sensed they want to replicate some
viruses don't activate the innate
response the the adaptive response very
well because they don't stimulate the
inflammatory response remember you have
to engage the innate response you get
inflammation and then you get engagement
of the adaptive response and some
viruses don't do that because they're
not good at stimulating innate responses
and these are usually viruses that don't
kill cells the non psychopathic viruses
and as I said
if you don't kill a cell you don't
release material that can be picked up
by the dendritic cells so cells are not
damaged they don't die of infection
there's no cytopathic effect so you
don't have an intrinsic response and you
don't have a very good innate immune
response so if you don't have an innate
immune response you don't have those
cytokines produced you don't have
inflammation and you never get to a good
adaptive response so the interaction of
non cytopathic viruses with the immune
system is very different from cytopathic
viruses because of all this and these
are typically Arina viruses like Lassa
fever virus they don't kill cells
paramyxovirus is like measles viruses
they typically cause persistent
infections because they can't be cleared
you don't have a good innate response
and therefore you cannot clear the
infection clearing an infection requires
a really good adaptive response so again
why don't you make a good in a response
because you don't make material that can
be sensed by the dendritic cells
oh the lessen the inflammatory response
heat swelling redness pain reflects the
communication of the innate and adaptive
immune defenses if you have no
inflammatory response you're going to
have a bad adaptive response and that's
because the cytokines aren't produced
that link the two processes together
this is one reason why we use adjuvant
in many vaccines that don't replicate so
there as we will see later in when we
talk about vaccines there are there are
many vaccines that are inactivated so
they don't infect you and so they don't
kill cells right because they can't get
in the cell and replicate so they're not
sensed very well by the innate response
and you don't get good inflammation and
if you don't get good inflammation you
don't get a good adaptive response and
if vaccines whole modus operandi says to
make a really good adaptive response so
sometimes we add adjuvant to these
vaccines and the purpose of those
adjuvant is to stimulate inflammation
because they have materials in them that
are sensed by the innate system and
induce these cytokines that you need to
a good adaptive response only a few
vaccines in the US have adjuvant so far
in Europe they use many more and there's
a lot of opposition to adjuvant but it's
probably not well justified we'll talk
more about that in vaccines so here's a
nice summary so far of what we're
talking about we're about to move into
adaptive responses but let's go back and
remember we have a nice mucosal surface
epithelial cells infected by a virus the
virus infected cells release if their
cells are killed they release products
which are picked up by immature
dendritic cells the in fact the cells
can also produce cytokines that help
them the dcs mature because remember the
dcs have receptors for those cytokines
the dcs mature they go to the lymph node
and they present viral peptides on their
surface to the T cells in the lymph node
the T cells mature and then those go out
into the circulation as well as
antibodies produced by b-cells
so here is our one slide summary of the
adaptive response which probably
maschwitz spent two weeks on or more we
have two arms that we have to keep in
mind you introduce some foreign antigen
protein viruses bacteria parasites fungi
into a vertebrate you have a humoral
response and a cell mediated response
the humoral response of course is the
production of antibodies by activated
b-cells
these antibodies can combine directly
with virus particles and render them
non-infectious so the antibody is is
important for preventing infection but
if you are already infected an antibody
has less of an importance it's good if
you already have the antibodies and
you're in fact it will prevent you from
being infected but when you are infected
for the first time by a virus it takes
two weeks or more to make antibodies and
so they don't really have a lot of role
in in your recovery what is important
for recovering from a virus infection is
the cell mediated response shown on the
right and that consists of of course
helper cells or cytotoxic t-lymphocytes
so these proceed from immature cells in
the bone marrow they go to the thymus
and then finally the lymph node and of
course there they can be activated by
dendritic cells which say look I have
some antigen and if it's a foreign
antigen these cells were mature so the T
helper cells the cd4 cells produce
cytokines that's their main role they
produce cytokines depending on the
subtype that either help b-cells mature
to make antibodies or they make
cytokines that help cd8 cells mature
into cytotoxic T cells so the th the cd4
th cells have a maturing role that CTL
is of course kill infected cells they
recognize when a cell is infected and
they kill it the idea being we're going
to stop any more virus replication of
course that damages cells and it is a
component of the pathology of infection
but it does limit infection in fact CT
ELLs are crucial for recovery for most
virus infections so if you want to
eradicate infected cells and virus
particles you need an adaptive response
you have to clear the infection and a
response cannot clear an infection once
it gets beyond a certain stage the
effectives are antibodies as we've said
that bind viruses and decrease the
number of infected cells and if you
remember they can also work with
complements so if you have an antibody
against the viral protein that's on the
cell surface complement will recognize
that and lyse the infected cell the T
cells will recognize infected cells and
of course they respond to viral antigens
on this the dendritic cells in the lymph
nodes it's how they get activated in the
first place they kill virus infected
cells and as I said the helper T cells
make cytokines to either aid in antibody
production or the maturation of of CTL s
so distinguishing the infected cell from
an uninfected self is done by the innate
immune system by the pattern recognition
receptors the toll-like receptors the
rig I like receptors even
compliment by recognizing for example
antibodies bound to the surfaces of
cells we haven't talked about NK cells
but they have of their own way of
recognizing self and non-self the
adaptive immune system recognizes this
this difference by antigen presentation
which we're not going to discuss at all
and you won't be responsible for but dr.
Silverstein will talk about ways that
viruses antagonize antigen presentation
as a means of evading adaptive responses
so you can find out more of that about
that in Chapter four let's talk a little
bit about antibodies that are made by
the adaptive response as I said these
are essential in the defense against
many infections when you get vaccinated
the reason that you are protected is
because you make antibodies against the
particular virus these do what we call
neutralize virus particles in the blood
so if the virus is spreading in your
blood you make antibodies the virus the
antibodies will combine with the virus
and that will block them from infecting
new cells they're also antibodies made
at mucosal surfaces the so called
secretory antibodies so if you have a
respiratory virus infection these can
bind the virus before it can even in
fact your mucosal epithelium that's what
I said right there and some even though
I told you that in general neutralizing
antibodies protect you there are some
examples where they're important for
recovery from infection so nothing is
ever absolute in science there's nothing
is ever black and white there are always
exceptions so if I say to you antibodies
are typically needed for protection
that's true but there are always
exceptions so there's some examples
where antibodies are needed for recovery
so here's an experiment which shows that
antibody protects against polio
infection
this is a passive antibody so you
remember we talked about passive Vyra
Mia a while ago passive Irena is when
you inject virus into an animal the
virus that first appears in the blood
say is passive by Rima because it's not
resulting from replication so these are
in a
that you inject they're not produced by
the animal they're just simply
antibodies you've injected so in this
experiment animals have been inoculated
with increasing amounts of antibodies so
the bigger number more antibody here's a
control animal with no antibody and then
they're infected with poliovirus so this
is percent paralyzed so almost all the
animals are paralyzed when you inject
them and there's no antibodies given and
then as you increase the amount of
antibody you protect them from paralysis
very clear experiment showing that you
can prevent infection with antibodies so
this is the basis of vaccination of
course so how do antibodies work to
prevent infection so here we're straight
inserter this using a Pokorny virus
rhinovirus and we're showing how this
virus gets into cells it binds receptors
on the cell surface it's taken up into
the cell by receptor mediated
endocytosis and the RNA is uncoated as
the pH in the endosome drops and on the
right are a series of scenarios showing
how antibodies that bind Rhino virus
could block infection so remember that
you're infected with Rhino virus your
adaptive system produces antibodies that
recognize these virus particles and they
will bind there'll be a whole set of
antibodies produced to all the proteins
and some of them will bind to the
surface of the virus itself the virion
some of these can block attachment of
the viruses to cells if you have enough
binding in the right places you will
block attachment of the virus and
thereby block its infectivity so that is
blocking before infection begins you can
also block later on you can have the
antibodies binding to the virus the
virus is still taken up into an endosome
but uncoding is blocked so there are
examples of antibodies that do this so
the particle gets all the way into the
cell but then when the pH drops the
antibodies prevent the changes in the
particle that are needed to get the RNA
out and finally you have antibodies that
aggregate viruses so that they're so
large
aggregates are so big they cannot be
taken up into the cells so three
different mechanisms of neutralization
this is how antibodies block infectivity
in various parts of you either your
blood or at mucosal surfaces so what are
these antibodies recognizing when when
antibodies are made of course they're
made against viruses that are broken up
by antigen presenting cells the peptides
are presented to b-cells
so you make antibodies against all the
possible peptides of a virus but the
ones that are important for us are the
antibodies that bind at the surface and
can block infection and these are two
examples of the epitopes recognized by
these antibodies so an epitope is a
short amino acid sequence that is
recognized by an antibody and all viral
proteins have epitopes in them but the
ones that we care about in this
discussion are the neutralizing epitopes
that is the ones where an antibody will
bind and block infection so that's what
we're showing here here on the left is a
structure of Rhino virus and we're
showing in the lighter colors some of
the neutralizing epitopes that is these
are short sequences to which antibodies
will bind and block infection so these
are on the surface of the particle and
they're in very specific places you can
see not every sequence isn't as a
neutralizing epitope so that's for a
virus with an icosahedral capsid here on
the right is the hemagglutinin of
influenza virus remember this is the
molecule on the surface of the virus
that binds to the receptor to get the
virus into a cell and that it also is
involved in fusing of the virus and cell
membrane at low pH and the colors show
you the neutralizing epitopes of the
gluten these are all mainly located at
the distal tip of the hemagglutinin so
the receptor binding area is right up
here and these colored areas are all
neutralizing epitopes so antibodies
would bind to these portions of the H a
and thereby block either attachment or
diffusion in the endosome now the one of
the reasons why influenza is a recurring
problem
it's because these epitopes mutate every
year you have amino acid changes in
these neutralizing epitopes so the
antibodies that you make one season
against influenza virus that neutralize
that virus very well the next year will
not neutralize it even just one or two
amino acid changes in one of these
epitopes will make the antibodies
ineffective and that's why with time we
have to be immunized against the new
strains of influenza that arise all
right so those are neutralizing
antibodies and the epitopes that they
recognize now cell mediated immunity as
I've said is essential for clearing most
virus infected most virus infections and
this is what we call the th1 response
the it is generated by a synapse form
between the cytotoxic t-lymphocytes and
the target cells that are infected with
viruses and the CTL is bind to the
target cell they recognize foreign
antigen on the surface of the targets of
the infected cell and they lyse them and
there are two ways that the CTL is lice
them one they transfer granules to the
target cell that have these these
proteins perforin and granzymes and they
poke holes in the target cell
effectively licen it and also they can
induce apoptosis so the engagement of
the CTL with an infected target cell can
turn on a pop tonic pathways which will
also cause the target cell to die so
here is an experiment where we look at
the role of antibodies versus cell
mediated immunity in protecting monkeys
against monkey pox infection so what we
have done here is we have immunized
these animals at day 0 and then we have
done something to the immune system here
either nothing the control or we deplete
the B cells or the cd8 cells which are
the CTLs the cytotoxic T cells so the B
cells of course making antibodies the
CTL is the cellular response so we're
going to tell which one is important
so in these animals vaccinated day zero
and no manipulation they make a nice
antibody response on day 22 if you take
away the b-cells the antibody response
is dampened so this is antibody titer
it's neutralizing titer so the larger
number is better and the ones depleted
of cd8 have slightly reduced but not a
bad antibody response then we infect
these animals with monkey pox on day 28
and we look at fatal infection and high
tide or replication so here these
animals who were immunized and not
manipulated are all protected from
lethal infection if we take away the
b-cells
three out of the four animals die if we
take away the t-cells the animals are
fine so here you can see if you have
antibodies ahead of time you're
protected from infection it doesn't
matter if you have t-cells the
antibodies are really what's important
but sometimes both antibody and cell
responses can play a role so here's
another experiment to show you that
we're looking at a virus replication on
the y axis either by RNA or plaque
forming units here and we have animals
who are infected they're all infected at
day zero and we have a control group
here in the open in the closed circles
and here's the titer of virus in the
serum it goes up and then then the
titers go down and about 30 percent of
the animals die if you deplete
antibodies from these animals they all
die and the virus cannot be controlled
so in the normally unmanipulated animals
they eventually control the ones who
survive control virus infection but if
you take away antibodies they cannot
clear the infection so that shows that
antibody is also important in this case
if you deplete cd8 cells you have 85%
death a little more death than the
controls but these guys are pretty good
at controlling the levels of virus
presumably because they have antibodies
so that's in the serum in the spleen you
can see the control group has a similar
pattern of virus production but if you
take away either antibodies or cd8 cells
these
the virus and the spleen cannot be
controlled so the control of virus
replication differs according to where
you look blood versus spleen same thing
with the brain if you take away
antibodies or cd8 cells you have a hard
time controlling virus titers so as I
said even though we we say that CD
eights are important for recovery and
antibody is important for infection
there are always exceptions to the rules
so but for some infections the CTL
response is more important than
antibodies and vice versa that's what
I've tried to illustrate by those couple
of experiments how do we make sure that
we have the right combination so
antibodies cellular responses how do we
modulate that data begins in the lymph
node when the mature dendritic cells
come in and talk to the T cells and
other lymphocytes that are present there
and it all has to do with th cells the
cd4 positive lymphocytes which remember
are just making cytokines that's their
role they can make cytokines that
stimulate the production of B cells or
CTLs and the direction really depends on
the virus so every virus and host
combination has a slightly different
need for B cell versus CTL and that's
controlled by these th cells remember
these cells in the lymph nodes make
contact with dendritic cells and also
macrophages that are patrolling and
bringing in foreign antigen they
exchange information this we've talked
about already today peptides and
cytokines and that causes the
differentiation of the cd4s into either
th one or th2 cells th 1 cells are those
that secrete cytokines that make the T
cells differentiated to cytotoxic T
cells and the th two cells make
cytokines that make B cells make
antibodies so you see there's a very
early decision point where you have to
decide you're going to go the B cell
route or the CTL route and that depends
on whether you make th one or th2 cells
and there seems to be a yin-yang
relationship if you have a lot of th one
sells low th2 and vice-versa you don't
make both at high levels so how do you
decide whether to make th one or th2
cells well most viral infections as I've
said are cleared by the th one cell the
cytotoxic T lymphocyte response th2
cells activate the antibody response
this is not a good response for most
virus infections remember with a few
exceptions that I showed you most virus
infections to be cleared need a CTL
response this is good for bacterial and
worm infections to make antibodies but
not for virus infections so what is the
response do you get what mixture of both
gets turned on and how and it's the
mixture of cytokines that are produced
by infected cells or Sentinel cells so
you have a precursor cell that can
either go to a th one or th two it's an
immature cd4 positive th cell and
remember in the lymph node these cells
are encountering the dendritic cells and
being activated by then the mix of
cytokines that are produced determines
whether they go to th one or the th 2
root so if you're making for example
il-2 12 and interferon gamma it pushes
you to the th one side or if you make al
four or five and ten you go the other
route now you don't need to know what
particular cocktail of cytokines pushes
it either way you just need to know that
the decision to go th one or th two is
based on which cytokines you get now
interestingly look here the suppression
of the th one response is is done by
some of the cytokines that induce the
th2 response so that's why I said this
was a yin-yang relationship you have
either one or the other high but not
both and again the kinds of cytokines
produced are presumably detected by the
static cells according to which pathogen
is present so they can sense that and
then the cd4 T cells respond by making
the right cocktail of cytokines these
adaptive responses also provide memory
this is very important
so that if you're infected later on you
get a more rapid and specific response
so the adaptive response takes two to
three weeks to engage fully if you're
reinfected it's much faster because you
have memory and eight responses don't
have that they're always on they respond
quickly they don't need to have memory
and this of course is the basis for
vaccination you're immunized and then
you encounter the pathogen some other
time and you respond quicker so you
prevent infection so you make antibodies
very quickly you block infection before
it starts and that's why antibodies will
prevent infection whereas if you have a
first encounter with the pathogen you
need the CTL response to clear it so
here's an experiment where we look at
antibody production after time so we
inject an animal with antigen a we have
a primary response three four weeks
after injections kind of modest and then
the antibody levels return to low levels
if you get infected or in this case
we're injecting antigen a seven weeks
down the road you have a very specific
and much more effective antibody
response against a so the curve goes up
higher and much more quickly and
eventually that goes down as well so
that's an example of memory you have
memory cells that will respond to this
antigen very quickly and more robustly
there is also cellular memory as well
not just antibody memory so there are B
cell memory and T cell memory that's
shown here here we have infected an
animal with a virus the titer rises this
is virus in the spleen and then it goes
back down again at the same time where
that animal is making cytotoxic
t-lymphocytes those are the green bars
and they are specific for the virus so
if you take the CTLs out of the animal
at these different time points you can
show that they will lyse virus infected
cells but eventually the activity of
those go down as well but still
circulating in the blood our epitope
specific lymphocytes so they don't kill
cells but they will recognize viral
epitopes so that means that there is
memory towards those cd8 lymphocyte
epitope so again there is not just
memory to
antibody antibody producing cells but
also CTLs as well and we'll talk more
about memory when we consider vaccines